hey Richard Gere you listening to me
you're like 60 years old dude stop being
so pretty and getting all these chicks
and everything you're making us young
guys feel inadequate every once in a
while there's this movie that just comes
along that you don't know anything about
this comes in your theater and you're
like you know what I'm gonna go see that
because you like the lead actor and it's
interesting to you and you have no idea
what it's about for some reason it's
really really good and you've never
heard of it arbitrage stars Richard Gere
Susan Sarandon
Brit Marling Nate Parker and Tim Roth
has this slimy sleazy little detective
Richard Gere plays a really successful
businessman and he has this front of
just very calm has everything in line
his family's beautiful they have the
money they need his business is thriving
he puts on this show for everyone that
everything's just fine underneath that
facade however he has a lot of things
that are going wrong and he's basically
at his breaking point
he's married to Susan Sarandon he has a
wonderful marriage with her he has all
these kids that's what it looks like
anyway he's actually cheating on her and
when something goes wrong with that
relationship that threatens his entire
family relationship as well as his
business he spends the rest of the film
trying to snake his way out of these
situations that he's now gotten himself
into we haven't located the driver the
driver yes someone else was driving what
happened do you hate this
hate when that happens this is a film
that all the action is in the dialogue
the story has got to be interesting it's
got to be a story that can make you feel
invested in it you got to care about
these characters and you're gonna want
to sit there for you know a hundred
minutes or so and watch them talking to
people and feel like you're actually
having a good time arbitrage does that
very successfully and that's because
this story is interesting and the
dialogue is good and the performances
are excellent they're top-notch it's the
best I've seen Richard Gere in a very
long time and I've always liked him too
I've always liked him as an actor and
this is definitely one of his better
performances I think he did a great job
in this movie see what screenplay is
nowadays most of them contain the
standard three act system it's a cliche
it's done over and over again if it's
done right it's cool if it's boring it's
boring you get introduced to a hero or a
main character in the first act then the
second act he is placed with some sort
of obstacles something he has to
overcome and in the third act he has
victory and we're all happy that's what
you generally see in movies and if you
look at most screenplays they all have a
variation of that most here this movie
has elements of that but its side steps
that by making the hero or the main
character actually be a fairly loathsome
individual who you are shocked that
you're actually caring about because of
all of the various things he
continuously does to himself his family
and his business he's not a hero at all
he's technically a villain it's just
that you start to care about him so much
and you're actually starting to feel
like yes I hope he gets out of this
situation despite the fact that you feel
like yeah actually in real life this guy
should be caught and put in jail and for
that reason they'll own this movie is
very successful because it can make you
care for this guy who you really
shouldn't be caring about the situation
would be men's look what would you
advise such a person to do
there's about 50 things that person
would nevado fingerprints DNA so phone
records that person were closing a
merger with a large bank any arrests
could derail the transaction and the
direction is pretty good it's nothing
terribly special but it gets the job
done Nate Parker from Red Tails you know
who yeah red tails no but yeah but he
was great in this movie and you really
started to feel for his character Tim
Roth I've always liked Tim Roth and he
gives an interesting twist to his
character as always he seems a little
off maybe Tim Roth just likes adding
little quirks to his characters if
you've ever seen four rooms starring Tim
Roth
that's about as quirky a Tim Roth as
you'll ever get but I would suggest
checking that out just for his
performance alone to the homicide no he
wants to pick them up the more time that
passes the more lives there's a tad bit
of pacing issues in the first maybe
twenty to thirty minutes of the film
before the plot really kicks in the film
could have been paced just a little bit
better but for the most part this was a
very interesting movie with a great
story I'm gonna give arbitrage a B+ just
in case you're wondering what that means
it's apparently the buying and selling
of various goods so yeah just let you
know not my partner you work for me you
brought this to our door everything I do
is for us for this family now you tell
me I don't run
thanks for watching guys and as always
if you like this then you can click
right here and get stuck mine eyes